hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrol au.l 2-3.3.1
Mr Arigato I am Bato I I'm like too
young for the 80s man
um well I grew up you know I was born in
the 80s so I'm not too young for these I
like the 80s
anyway beside the point uh create and
retain system audit logs and Records to
the extent needed to enable the
monitoring analysis investigation and
reporting of unlawful or unauthorized
system activity
[Music]
all right
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist sp800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmmccontrol
au.l1-3.3.1 create and retain system
audit logs and Records the extent needed
to enable the monitoring analysis
investigation and reporting of unlawful
or unauthorized system activity
oh boy here we go we're back with one of
the most misunderstood controls and
Concepts in cmmc and I'm gonna make it
all clear with one easy phrase are you
ready you need a seam Solution that's it
that's what you need to know on this one
and if you have no idea what it is you
help your YouTube
and pick up the other phone with your
left hand you should call us uh look you
need a seam solution all right even if
you have no idea what that is you should
just uh well you need one all right so
uh again either way it's going to cost
you way less time and money uh to put
one of these in place well it's the only
thing you really can do to be compliant
so just call someone will help but of
course we're not going to totally leave
you hanging there uh with my
unbelievably awesome unscripted script
here uh that's not how we roll it on
call I will give you a little help
because giving people help is what we do
and we love doing it and we love doing
it for free we love doing it even more
when you pay and you know real talk it
pays the bills because I don't get paid
to do these these awesome YouTube videos
which is why the quality is so
incredibly amazing you should see how
much revenue we drive off YouTube videos
exactly all right I will at least tell
you that a seam or security information
event management solution is something
that ingests the log files from the
computers and other devices like
firewalls and turns it into useful
security alerts and relevant information
so your network is always being properly
washed over and you're always getting
timely enough alerts that you can
actually use to take action with all
right so I always ask people I say hey
how is your network monitored and when
they don't really have an answer I know
they don't really have a seam solution
and I typically know yuck it's a bad
situation anyway let's check out what
the assessors are looking for and how to
make them happy uh assessment Point
number one determine if audit logs
needed I.E event types to be logged to
enable the monitoring analysis
investigation and reporting of unlawful
unauthorized system activity are
specified so are the logs
that will enable information to flow
your way is it specified the answer is
going to be yes right we're going to
pull system logs and firewall logs and
manage switch logs and I know whatever
else is relevant to your environment
maybe it's Azure government uh you know
uh logs and we're going to feed it all
into our seam system
right so the seam system kind of does
that but first we determine that we've
installed seam log senders or agents or
whatever it may be for your solution
onto those devices we have to Define
define those devices all right Point
number two determine if the content of
the audit law of to determine if the
content of audit records needed to
support monitoring analysis
investigation and reporting of unlawful
unauthorized system activity is defined
so
are we defining what the content of
those audit records is again your seam
system kind of does this for you because
it's just puking out all of the logs uh
or you're defining what the logs are
that are being sent to that system so
either way you can have it defined your
seam system is what ingests it
next we have to determine if audit
records are created okay do we create
audit records when the information is
ingested into the seam system okay this
is built into the seam system but
nonetheless I have run into clients
especially big ones who have like
cobbled together their own seam system
uh out of you know a great example is
like elastic right so elastic is a
solution out there where you can really
customize what goes in there so we want
to make sure that again there's an audit
record Being created as part of the pro
process next point is determine if audit
records uh once created contain the
defined content okay so do uh do the
audit records actually contain the
content defined as well what you're
trying to audit so again we say hey look
we can look at our our seam system it's
all kind of there uh you know it's
unknown right now how deeply the
assessors will really want to dive into
the the nitty-gritty here like do they
want a written policy where you've read
written out every kind of audit record
type that you're going like that's
extreme I think if you've got a seam
system this whole control really is
pretty easy to answer final excuse me
final two points all right determine if
retention requirements for audit records
are defined most team systems are gonna
uh have at least 30 days worth of
Records we tell our clients look I think
you should have at least 90 days to 93
days why because again in dfar 7012 the
dod has 90 days to request you pull
records back so they can do a forensic
investigation that's the actual
rationale there if you will
and then the final assessment point is
determine if audit records are retained
as defined so uh again is there a
retention policy and then go actually uh
sort of verify that they are in fact
being retained in accordance with the
policy the policy is active linked Etc
so this is probably going to be a
demonstration
you're likely going to have an assessor
asked to see your same system or at
least the audit record example uh you
know that could just be a simple
over-the-shoulder shoulder surf or again
some kind of demonstration that's
actually working
so um yeah that's uh you know no problem
at all right only seven assessment
points any of which can fail you I hope
you get it right just kidding the good
news is we can help you get it right and
that's what this video is all about
helping you guys so look at on-call we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this D fars nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped in
their laps like a seagull on a sunny day
and we teach you how to level up and be
a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
as your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's when becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
we're even better here it comes here it
comes get your get your finger ready
here it is
smash that subscribe button baby to get
the latest compliance content as soon as
our compliances roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]